i just saw you were shooting a video
with j stone yeah we're doing another
one today i'm locking in um
we're putting a little little little
project a little ep
you know cause you know me and nick was
gonna do one you know what i mean
guaranteed we was already talking about
that
so i'm gonna do i'm doing with stone
yeah shout out to stone man i think i
think um
you know he was always like slept on for
sure
and stolen a good just a good good [__]
you know what i'm saying like i just
just vibed like
we uh we vibe good
y'all hear the music that's why i'm just
we we've been just trying to knock out
how many records you guys got done
right now i think we might be like three
or four
three or four one we shot the video the
other day uh in this other i think we're
shooting one today
you you and nipsey were supposed to do a
project i remember we talked about that
before
did you guys have any um music that you
that that's
just sitting on a hard drive somewhere
that y'all never released how many
unreleased songs you think you got with
nick
maybe three there's one with me him and
being over never put out
we're beating riddle being on combat
three two that was another
shout out to beno beano's fire that's my
boy def jam yeah that's my boy
uh and then me and him got two two
drinks i had one record that i was gonna
put on comment three but
yeah i was gonna ask you like is it is
it um obviously you're tight with his
team but like
is it like kind of weird putting
something out with you like with him
after he passed you know what i'm saying
i feel like
super weird like the
the um the excitement is going
behind it i'm still excited to do it and
you know let it be known that we did
that and created that but the
phone call yo cause you just ready to
drive like all that's gone you know i
mean so it's it's definitely weird
you i think a lot of people have always
kind of said you're kind of like
what nip is to what nip was to la to
your hood to harlem
right to to like new york somebody who
is like a man of the people somebody
who's never really
damn i got my ringtone on unprofessional
but somebody who uh who you know
when i think of davies i never ever have
ever thought of goofy [__] or
i think of integrity i think of you know
when it comes to music and it just comes
to you as a person like
um what was you know obviously you know
you've done a ton of interviews since
nipsey passed um but
we're going on a year and a half since
he died
what is the one thing you think since he
passed
um that you've carried with you and that
you're like like from
nip to this day because you know [__]
man i can't even believe it's been a
year and a half right
like i would say just uh
his motto marathon you know what i'm
saying like the [__] he lived by the
[__] he always said
don't stop you know what i mean like no
matter what what come your way
you gotta keep keep keep rolling you
know i mean and
the fact of ownership and
turning your brand into a business and
just being more than a rapper
and i mean so that's what really stuck
with me the most
and just trying to build my brand from
just being dave east you know i mean to
where that [__] being something else i
want to build an empire